- So as you can see, my topic
today is the right to strike.
And strikes have been on
people's minds lately,
although there has been this
great decrease in strike
activity.
There's been the Day
Without Immigrants.
There has been the
women's strike.
There was the taxi
driver strike in New York
during the protests against
Trump's immigration ban.
We're near May
1-- in a few days,
we're May 1, which is
International Labor Day,
and hundreds of
thousands of workers
have said that they're going
to go on strike that day.
Hopefully that's true.
And we've seen wider
protests here and abroad
that have taken the form
of various kinds of strike
activity.
Which has all
raised the question,
why do workers have
the right to strike?
And there are different
accounts, for instance.
Some say that
workers have a right
to strike because they enjoy a
kind of freedom of association
in the economy,
and that's the way
to understand their
right to strike.
Others say that
workers have a right
to strike because it's necessary
to make their bargaining
power roughly equal
with their employers,
and that's what
allows us to think
of the labor contract as fair.
And then others, like me,
think that the right to strike
is better understood as a
right to resist oppression.
Now what I really want to
argue today is two things,
or that argument
really has two parts.
The first is just to get
across and communicate
why it matters how we
justify the right to strike.
There are these different
accounts available,
and it really matters how we
justify the right to strike.
And I'll spend about the
first half of the talk giving
an account of why it matters how
we justify the right to strike.
And then in the second
half of the talk,
I will explain why I
think the right to strike
is best understood as a
right to resist oppression.
So here is a way to--
here's a kind of
dilemma that I think
illustrates why it matters how
we justify the right to strike.
In one sector of
the labor market,
we have relatively high-skilled
or specialized workers
who are pretty hard to
replace, so doctors or sports
players or professors.
Specialized-- I didn't
say high-skilled,
I just said specialized,
hard to replace.
Or the 40,000 Verizon workers
who went on strike last year,
the ones who install and
service the fiber optic cables.
They turned out to be
pretty hard to replace.
Now for workers like this to go
on strike, all they have to do
is refuse to work.
It requires a bit of
organization, discipline,
solidarity.
But if they want
to go on a strike
and have some reasonable
chance of success,
then they can
simply stop working.
And because they're
hard to replace,
they have a pretty good chance
of significantly slowing
down or stopping production and
winning some of their demands.
Now these are workers who tend
to be pretty well compensated,
enjoy pretty good benefits,
have pretty good or relatively
better job security.
Now compare them
with the majority
of workers in other sectors
of the labor market--
so service, agriculture, basic
industry, transportation.
I'm talking like Wal-Mart
workers or Amazon warehouse
workers or poultry processors
or restaurant workers.
These tend to be workers who
enjoy relatively low wages,
longer hours, work
in worse conditions,
enjoy less job security.
And they tend to be
much easier to replace.
The relatively
lower skill, that's
usually why they're
relatively easy to replace.
Now for workers like
this to go on strike
and have some reasonable
chance of success,
it's not enough for them
simply to refuse to work.
They have to also
in some way either
prevent their bosses
from hiring replacements,
or prevent replacements
from taking those jobs
and crossing a picket
line, or in some other way
prevent work from happening.
To do that, they have to resort
to much more coercive strike
tactics.
I'm talking about
things like sit-downs,
which are occupations
of a workplace,
or mass pickets, which
involve surrounding
a workplace with a
kind of wall of workers
so that no managers or employers
or suppliers can get in or out.
Or even sometimes sabotage,
disabling or destroying
some piece of machinery
or the relevant objects
so that work can't take place.
And just to give you a sense
of what this looks like,
I've got some slides.
So here a sit-downs.
I should say I'm taking
most of my examples
from the American
labor experience,
but it's not because the
United States is some kind
of an exception in this case.
The argument I'm
developing applies
to all liberal capitalist
societies in particular.
I just know the
American case the best.
In some ways, it's a
little bit more extreme,
but it's not exceptional.
So sit-downs-- the heyday of
sit-down strikes in the United
States was the 1930s.
These were Woolworth waitresses
who were sitting down
in the kind of cafes in
Woolworth's where they worked,
and they occupied
Woolworth's demanding
I think it was union
recognition, better
wages, and better hours.
These were the same counters
that 30 years later would
become quite famous when they
were the subject of the sit-ins
during the civil rights
movement in the South.
We have women cigar rollers
occupying a factory--
I think this is Chicago--
occupying a cigar-rolling
factor, demanding better pay,
recognition, and also not having
to breathe in such toxic fumes
from all of the tobacco
in the warehouse.
And they had been inspired
by the very successful Flint
sit-down strike, which
was a strike against auto
manufacturing company
in Flint, Michigan.
And this is a somewhat
misleading picture
because it gives the impression
that sit-down strikes
for these very peaceful,
leisurely affairs.
But you get a feel
for how it works.
You occupy the factory.
By the end of the 1930s, this
tactic was declared illegal.
Workers had a right to
strike, but this tactic
was declared illegal--
outside the bounds of
the right to strike.
And so the tactic
somewhat faded from view.
But occasionally it reappears.
So during the financial
crisis of 2008,
Chicago-based company
Republic Windows and Steel
was the subject of a strike.
There had been a
financial scandal,
and it was going to close.
And I think the mostly Latino
workforce occupied the building
until they forced
the company basically
to sell it to an employer that
would continue to employ them.
And so it was a successful
incident of a sit-down strike.
So that's what
sit-downs look like.
You also have mass pickets.
These are actually Japanese
miners from I think 1960.
I like this one just because
it's a really intense mass
picket.
I mean, that's
layers upon layers
of workers completely
obstructing
any access to the work site.
But in the United States,
the heyday of mass pickets
was also the 1930s and 1940s.
So this is a mass picket during
the longshoreman's strike,
which was a West Coast strike
that extended from Los Angeles
through San Francisco,
Portland, and this is Seattle.
Mass pickets were also declared
illegal in the United States
by 1940, but they still
did reappear on occasion.
So this is the famous
sanitation worker strike
in Memphis, Tennessee, which is
the strike that Martin Luther
King was supporting when
he was assassinated.
And this is one
where they engaged
in a mass picket that shut
down commerce in the streets.
And during the Verizon
strike last year,
there was a mass
picket for a day
in New York that shut down some
commerce entering the city.
It was a one-day mass picket.
Now part of the reason I'm
showing you these images--
besides I think they're kind
of objectively interesting
and they give you a feel for
what it's like to actually
engage in these sort of
mass strike tactics--
is to illustrate the dilemma.
And the dilemma is this.
These kinds of strike tactics--
sit-downs, mass
pickets, sabotage--
are on the one hand necessary
for these easily-replaced
workers to use if
they're going to engage
in a strike that has some
reasonable chance of success.
But they're extremely coercive.
And they're not just
generally coercive.
They involve violating some of
the basic economic and civil
liberties that every liberal
capitalist society protects.
Violates the property
rights of owners.
And it violates by extension
the managerial authority
of those owners' managers.
It also violates the freedom
of contract and freedom
of association of replacement
workers, who normally
are considered to be free to
take jobs that are offered
to them and can't
just be blocked
from accepting those jobs.
And in general, they also
tend to kind of disrupt
the general public
sense of law and order
because that's usually equated
with the free flow of commerce.
And so the problem is this.
In a liberal capitalist
society, usually the kind
of basic principle
of political morality
is that we extend basic
economic, civil, and political
liberties to
everyone on condition
that nobody
interferes with anyone
else and their exercise of those
same basic economic liberties.
But if that's the
principle, then it's
unclear on what basis
you could justify
the use of these highly-coercive
tactics by strikers.
And so there's a question.
What has priority--
these basic economic
and civil liberties that every
liberal capitalist society
endorses, or the
right to strike?
So this is the dilemma.
And I bring it up because
it shows why we really
have to decide what we think
the justification of the right
to strike is.
Because depending on
how we justify it,
we'll either think that the
right to strike has priority
or we'll think that these basic
economic and civil liberties
have priority.
But let me turn the heat
up a little bit more
and show you that the
stakes are even higher.
You might end up with blackouts.
The stakes are even higher
because if you decide
that the basic economic and
civil liberties have priority,
then you also think
the state is authorized
or it is acting rightly
when it goes and represses
the use of these coercive
strike tactics by strikers.
If a mass picket or sit-down
is an unjust, illegitimate
violation of property
rights or contract rights,
then it is right
for the state to use
its coercive legal authority
to go and break up strikes.
And by far and away,
most of the violence
that is associated
with strikes has
to do with these kinds
of mass strike tactics
and with the state going in
and deciding to break them up.
And here is just a quick,
completely inadequate
visual history of
that experience
of strike repression.
And it begins in
the 19th century.
1886 is a major strike
wave in the United States.
Most of the images of strike
repression from that period
is in etchings and sketches
because you didn't have
on-the-scene photographers.
And this is the police breaking
up a mass picket during that
a kind of a march during
striking streetcar workers.
And I raise this in
particular because this
is the period in which
police became militarized.
The origins of
the militarization
of the police in the
United States and elsewhere
is when they acquire the
role of strikebreakers.
They get weapons, military
training, uniforms,
professional training.
Here's the Lawrence textile
strike, one hour north
in Lawrence, Massachusetts.
When the police
were inadequate, you
brought in the National Guard.
And Harvard students
got time off
to go serve as strikebreakers
during that strike.
Not accidentally, the
president of Harvard
was one Lowell from a
famous textile family.
Sometimes the National
Guard brought machine guns.
And this is a
strike in Colorado,
which later ended
in massive violence
against the Ludlow strikers.
About 20 of them
died when the camp
was attacked by the National
Guard and set aflame.
And this is San Francisco
during that dockworker strike.
It is interesting how
frequently in the archives
one finds photographs of
tanks occupying cities
during strikes.
Probably the most
frequent use of tanks
until the American
involvement in World War II,
that would be my guess.
I'm not sure anyone's
documented it.
This is a street battle
during the general strike
in Minneapolis.
And you see kind of a picket
line set up there with the use
of stalled automobiles.
And this is fighting with the
police during the battle of--
I think it was the
battle of the overpass.
There are also private
security forces.
So every major business had
its own private sort of army.
A congressional
inquiry in '39 found
that GM had a private security
force of 1,200 armed contract
servicemen.
And this is the Ford
so-called service department.
That's how they
called these guys.
But their only job was to beat
up labor organizers and strike
organizers.
And this is police who shot
on an unarmed mass picket
during a steel strike in '37.
This is the Memphis strike.
So in the Memphis strike they
brought in armored personnel
carriers--
I think it's the
National Guard--
to restore and
maintain public order.
That's the police beating
up some of the strikers.
This is a strike in
Charleston, South Carolina.
This is just a random--
I could have pick out any old--
I mean, there's a million
photographs like this.
There's nothing special
about this strike.
It's just another strike with
mass pickets and the police
breaking it up.
This is janitors
striking in LA in 1990.
And this is Harvard
Square in 2013.
Not a mass strike just a
small strike by about--
how many was it, Joe--
eight, 10 employees.
It was a small picket 20?
And this is the police
suppressing this very small
little strike violently.
And the police are being sued--
I think that's the
person who's suing them
for brutality during
the suppression
of this particular strike.
So the reason I've put
these images on display
is they remind us of sort
of the stakes of deciding
why we think workers
have the right to strike
and how we come down on this.
Because if we end up
deciding that workers are not
justified in using these sort
of more coercive strike tactics
like mass pickets
and sit-downs, then
whenever they get
it in their mind,
or even when they use slightly
less coercive tactics,
then we end up saying that
the state has the authority
to coercively enforce
the laws, which
means breaking up
these strikes and use
a great deal of violence.
But if you end up thinking
that the right to strike
has a degree of priority,
then we not only think--
or we might end up
deciding-- not only
that these uses of force are
severely unjust and oppressive,
but that workers sometimes
have a right to resist
this use of coercive authority.
And things like the
battle of the overpass
were reasonable
responses by workers
in the face of this
oppressive use of force.
So that's hopefully
a convincing version
of my first point, which is that
it matters why we think workers
have the right to strike.
So why do I say that the
best account is the right
to strike as a right
to resist oppression?
Well, to give a persuasive
account of that,
I think I have to convince
you of two things.
First, that there really
is systematic oppression
in the economy.
And then that the right
to strike as a right
to resist oppression
is the best way
of responding to those facts.
So what do I mean by oppression?
Well, by oppression, I just mean
the systematic and organized
unfair limitation
of people's freedom.
Not accidental or occasional,
but systematic and organized
unfair limitation
on people's freedom.
So why do I say the
economy is oppressive?
Let me give you some
examples and then step back
and say what I think
these are examples of.
And again, my examples
are from the American case
because I know it best, but I've
been educated by my research
assistants on the way in which
this is true of other economies
as well.
So let's take the example
of Wal-Mart employees.
Wal-Mart-- I think the
largest private employer
and something like 16 states.
So Wal-Mart employees, when they
were working the night shift
restocking shelves and
cleaning the premises,
can be locked in
the store overnight.
And if they need
to get out, they
have to call their managers,
hopefully wake someone up,
have them come unlock the door,
and only then can they leave.
Regardless of whatever
the emergency is,
they can be locked indoors.
Amazon warehouse employees-- the
people who were like packaging
the stuff that shows
up on your door--
in the summer
months, they are made
to work in warehouses that are
so hot that Amazon has been
known to park emergency
vehicles outside the warehouse
to rush anyone who succumbs
to heat exhaustion to the ER.
And Amazon keeps it hot
because it reduces their air
conditioning costs.
Moreover, it turns out that
it's a legal power for Amazon
to keep its employees
in security lines for up
to an hour after the
workers are off the clock--
so they've punched out,
they're not getting paid--
to check to see if they've
been stealing anything
from the warehouse.
And this is a job requirement.
So they're required to do
it as part of their job,
but they're not paid for
it because they're not
said to be doing any work.
A recent report-- I
think it was by Oxfam--
found that poultry workers
in poultry processing--
major poultry processing
plants in the United States--
were coming to work
wearing diapers.
And the reason that they
were wearing diapers
was because they
didn't have enough time
during their personal
breaks to take care of all
of their personal business.
And if they asked for any
further break like a bathroom
break, their managers
regularly denied their request,
regardless of whether they
were sick or pregnant--
in some cases, they
were pregnant women--
or just any human being we
need to use the bathroom
because they didn't
happen to go the bathroom
during the personal break.
And if you think this is
only a feature of a poultry
processing, one
of the grievances
of some of the workers
during the Verizon strike
was that if they were up on
a upon a pole or on a roof
installing some fiber optic
cable and it was summer
and they were hot and they
needed to use the bathroom
or get a glass of
water, they were first
being required to
call their manager,
get approval from their
manager to go to the bathroom.
And if they didn't
get that approval
and went to the bathroom
anyway or got the drink anyway,
they would end up in
disciplinary proceedings, dock
of pay, or limitation of hours.
And if they did this more than
once, they could be fired.
Now the point about all
of these-- oh sorry,
I forgot one that I think
is particularly important.
For many of these workers--
especially Wal-Mart workers,
people in restaurant
work, retail--
they have no idea week to
week what exactly their hours
are going to be.
They might work the same hours.
They make work fewer.
They might be more hours
but different hours
than the week before.
So extremely difficult
for any of them
to organize their lives on any
rational, predictable basis.
For those of you with
children, imagine.
Without children, I imagine.
I mean, you don't have
to have children, but--
I was home yesterday
with my kid.
That's why that
one's on my mind.
Imagine that you have
no idea what you're
going to do week to week.
Now the important feature
of all these examples
is that they are all
examples of legal powers
that managers have exercised
over their employees.
None of these were examples
of something that was illegal.
They are all forms
of legal authority
that managers exercise in the
workplace over their employees.
And in fact, it's a general
fact of the typical workplace
in any liberal
capitalist society
that managers enjoy a wide
swath of uncontrolled authority
over their employees-- to
control hours and scheduling,
to control the introduction
of new technologies
or the definition of
tasks, to determine who
gets what kinds of breaks,
to determine various hiring
and firing practices, and other
aspects of working conditions.
Once we become
aware of that fact,
it's fair to say that the
workplace is best understood
as a site of government.
A workplace isn't just a kind
of place of free exchange
or private relationships.
It is a site of government.
But it's not just any
old site of government.
It's an extremely hierarchical,
somewhat despotic form
of government, because
it's one in which those
who are subject to commands
by the people who govern them
have very little formal legal
control over those commands.
And to kind of
put a point on it,
in other essential
social institutions,
we don't accept this
kind of authority.
For instance, the family is
no longer organized legally
as a patriarchy.
One person isn't just
formally subject to the will
of one of the other adults who
are party to that relationship.
The state is also not a monarchy
or an enlightened despotism.
We think that the only
legitimate form of state
is one in which those who
are subject to its authority
have roughly equal control over
its commands and directives.
But the workplace,
I think, is fairly
said to be highly
oppressive because it's
a site of arbitrary
authority over which workers
have very limited formal
and legal control.
It's deeply hierarchical,
and it involves authority
over many of the
intimate details
of the way in which people use
their time on a daily basis.
So that's one aspect of the
oppression of the economy.
But it's unfortunately
even worse than that.
Because why do people end up
in these kinds of workplaces
and these types of authoritarian
relationships in the workplace?
Well, this is where
we have to appreciate
the broader structural
sources of oppression.
The reason that people end
up in workplaces like this
is because of the
deeply unequal,
legally-protected control
over property and wealth.
There are some people
in the economy who
have no reasonable
alternative but to find a job
and earn money.
They have no
reasonable alternative
because they have no other way
of meeting their basic needs.
The only way in which they can
get a reliable source of income
is by getting a job.
So those people are
forced to work right.
While there's another
group of people
who in virtue of
the wealth that they
have accumulated or inherited
are not forced to work.
They might, but they're
not forced to work.
And so the basic
structure of the economy
is one in which you have
a deeply unequal system
of forcing some to work while
others are not forced to work.
But it's not just that some
are forced to work while others
aren't.
But those who are
forced to work have
to work for those who control
employment and investment.
So some work for others.
And in the typical
case, this means
that those who
are forced to work
are forced to enter these
workplaces that are typically
characterized by these
deeply hierarchical relations
of authority.
Which then ends up meaning,
because of the broader
structure of dependence of those
who work on those who employ--
it ends up meaning that
employers and their managers
even enjoy certain
kinds of material power
that go beyond the
legal power they enjoy.
So just to give you
one headline example.
I was reading the other
day a recent study
which showed that
American workers are
subject to between
$8 and $14 billion
worth of wage theft a year.
And they just have to take it.
And this wage theft
is concentrated
almost entirely in the service
sector and in agriculture,
in the kind of worst
jobs where workers
and have the worst
economic opportunities.
So this is an example
of another layer
of the oppression in so far
as managers can often get away
with a lot of things when
it comes to workers who
have the least amount of
power in the economy, over
and above the legally protected
authority that they have.
So this is why I
think it makes sense
to say that the economy isn't
just somewhere where wealth is
produced, where people's
standards of living
are determined, but is
in fact best understood
as a structure of
power and authority
that places enormous
restraints on some people's
freedom and much less restraint
on other people's freedom--
and that this is
deeply unjustified
and is therefore oppressive.
So that's step one
of the argument
for seeing the right
to strike as a right
to resist oppression.
The second step, then, with
these facts in mind, we can--
yeah, stop showing
pretty pictures
because this is the part
that isn't like fun,
about the argument I guess.
I sort of thought, how do
I show pictures about this,
but I've already done it.
So the second step
is, then, what
do we do with these
facts about the economy,
and how does this help us
evaluate the different accounts
of the right to strike?
Well, one account of
the right to strike--
which we can call liberal.
The labels don't matter.
It's just to fix ideas--
which is the liberal view, which
is that workers have a right
to strike because they already
enjoy freedom of association.
And the right to
strike is just the way
in which you exercise your
freedom of association
in the economy.
Now there are two really simple
problems with this account.
First, it doesn't
connect the right
to strike to any
economic injustice.
It doesn't say workers
are right to strike
because there's something
unjust about any economy.
In fact, it assumes that
there's something fair
about the economy where we
protect this civil liberty,
and here's one way in
which it can be exercised.
But what this
further means, then,
is that the right to
strike has to be limited
by the normal
limitations that apply
to the economic and
civil liberties.
So workers who exercise the
right to strike in this sense
can associate together.
They can try and go on strike.
But they have to
respect everybody else's
basic economic and civil
liberties because that just
goes hand-in-hand with
thinking that this
is an exercise of
freedom of association.
So on this account, workers
have a right to strike,
but it's one that could only
be meaningfully exercised
by the hardest to replace
workers since those are really
the only ones who could
possibly carry off
a strike in such a peaceful
and non-coercive manner.
So this seem to me a
deeply inadequate way
of thinking about
the right to strike.
Another version-- which
we call social democratic,
but again doesn't
matter the label--
is to say well, no,
the right to strike
does address an injustice,
which is that workers sometimes
have somewhat unequal
bargaining power in the economy.
And it's only when we protect
labor rights, including a right
to strike, that we can say
that the contracts that workers
strike with their employers
are truly free or really fair.
So in this sense, it's a
way of really realizing
one of the civil liberties
that are nominally
protected in a standard liberal
capitalist constitution.
This is reasonable.
This seems to me a
reasonable account.
Certainly gets us some truth.
There is an important economic
injustice that it identifies.
But the problem with the account
is that it's far too narrow.
It represents the
problem of power
as just a question of
the bargaining power
that employees have with
their employers at the moment
of making the contract.
It says nothing directly either
about the background structure
of oppression that involves
forcing some people to work
and not others, the background
control over property,
and investment in
employment that
is its own independent
source of oppression.
So it has nothing to
say directly about that
and just assumes that that
structure remains in place.
And has nothing directly to
say about the relationships
of domination in the
workplace itself.
Those are incidental questions.
So it's far too narrow
an understanding
of the kind of injustice that
we can see a right to strike to,
and ends up narrowing
the kinds of things
that workers may
legitimately strike over.
It usually tends to be about
wages and benefits rather than
any of these other
broader questions of power
and authority in the economy.
So what's distinct, then,
about seeing the right
to strike as a right
to resist oppression?
Well, I think the
first point is to say
that when we understand the
right to strike as a right
to resist oppression, we're
saying that strikes can
be about the full array
of unjust limitations
on workers' freedom.
Strikes can be about things
like particular policies that
affect the
distribution of control
over property and investment.
Or strikes can be about various
grievances and exercises
of managerial authority.
So if we see it as a right
to resist oppression,
then it's a way of
arguing for the right
to strike in a way that's
responsive to the entirety
of the injustices that I'm
saying exist in the economy.
And I should just add
that you might not
agree with every aspect
of my characterization
of the economy.
But so long as you
agree that there
are some deep and systematic
injustices in the economy that
can't just be resolved by
altering the terms of a labor
contract, then I think this
particular view should still
be persuasive to you.
Because the point is
that you don't assume
that the only moment or site
at which this oppression exists
is at the moment
when workers make
contracts with their employers.
It also extends past the
time of contract and prior,
to the fact that they're
forced into the labor market
on an equal terms
in the first place.
So that's the first
point about why
I think seeing it as a
right to resist oppression
is more responsive to
the kinds of injustices
and the concern
for freedom that I
think animates the best argument
for the right to strike.
Just emphasize,
the point is to say
that what really
drives this argument is
to say that what
workers are demanding
or what workers should
be free to demand
isn't just higher levels of
income or better benefits,
but greater freedom and
therefore resistance
to the wide array of
forms of unfreedom
that they face in the economy.
The second advantage that
I think this view has
is that it means that
the right to strike
is shaped in a way that
allows it to actually protect
the interest that justifies it.
I know that sort of an
obscure way of saying it.
So by shape, I just mean
that the shape of a right
is what kinds of
permissions and restrictions
there are on it's exercise.
Now we saw in the
other two cases
the shape of their version
of the right to strike
was limited by the
need to respect
the basic economic
and civil liberties
because that way of
thinking derived the right
to strike from those basic
economic and civil liberties.
But this way of thinking--
the right to strike
as a right to resist
oppression-- just begins
from the basic interest
that workers have in
exercising their freedom,
exercising their
collective capacity
to reduce the oppression
to which they're subject.
Which means that the right
must include permission
to use some kinds of
means that gives them
a reasonable chance of actually
resisting that oppression.
It won't just import these
restrictions that normally
apply to basic civil liberties.
So I think that's
a further advantage
is it's more suitably tailored
to the aim is supposed
to promote, which is to give
workers the actual capacity
to use their own agency to
resist the oppression they
face.
The third and I think
final superiority
of this particular
way of thinking
is that it also explains
why the right to strike
enjoys priority over these basic
economic and civil liberties
in the case of labor disputes,
which is the following.
If the right to strike is a
right to resist oppression
and the oppression that
workers are resisting
is a product of the way
in which the law protects
these basic economic
and civil liberties,
then those basic economic and
civil liberties-- at least
when it comes to the
economy-- are not
worthy of very much respect.
Because it's the protection
of those particular liberties
that creates the oppression
in the first place.
And in fact, whatever
claim to respect
those liberties have
is actually a claim
for the right to strike.
Because it's actually in
the exercise of the right
to strike that workers
come closer to demanding
the kind of equal
freedom that is the basis
for any reasonable
account of just economic
and social relationships.
So this way of thinking
about the right to strike
answers the question in a
way that's both coherent
and establishes it's
own limitations.
It's just an argument about
why the right to strike
would have priority over basic
economic and civil liberties
like property rights,
freedom of contract,
freedom of association
in the economy,
and even general counts
of law and order.
Because when the law
protects those rights,
it actually creates
the very oppression
that the right to
strike is a response to.
Since the normal justification
of those basic economic and
civil liberties is
that they create
a kind of fair or just
system of social cooperation,
but they in fact just create
this highly unequal system
of forcing coercion
and domination,
it's actually the right to
strike that has a better
claim to having priority.
So we can see then how, if
you think about the right
to strike this way, we resolve
the dilemma that I began
with in a very different way.
We say that as a feature
of their right to strike it
is permissible,
perhaps even good,
that workers don't respect the
property rights of employers
and the authority of
managers, and instead
demand better terms by using
some of these coercive tactics.
Now let me just conclude
with two thoughts.
I'm sure at this
point some of you
are thinking, well, sounds like
you think strikers can do just
whatever they want.
And that's not what I'm arguing.
I'm arguing something narrower.
I'm saying that this central
dilemma about whether strikers
have the permission to violate
certain property rights
and other basic economic
and civil liberties
in the context of
labor disputes,
whether that's permitted.
I'm saying that particular--
the normal respect we accord
to basic economic and civil
liberties isn't required
because what strikers are doing
are actually demanding fairer
terms of social cooperation.
They're demanding more freedom
than they currently enjoy.
But that doesn't mean that they
can just do anything they want.
It doesn't mean all moral
rules on human behavior
are suspended.
It just means our normal respect
for these basic liberties
isn't as strong.
Secondly, I imagine some of
you are also wondering or maybe
saying yourselves,
well, OK, it's
true that the economy
is deeply unjust.
But why bother with
the right to strike?
Why not just argue for something
else, like a fairer economy?
Now I'm seeing all the nods.
Well, the reason is because
I think that's a complete non
sequitur So the
question is, what
may those who suffer
oppression do to resist
the oppression they face?
The answer is not, well, we
should have a non-oppressive
economy because that's
telling people--
in light of an ideal that
is incredibly unfeasible
and unbelievably remote--
they shouldn't try and resist
the oppression where they are.
It's a kind of
apology for quietism.
There are good
reasons for wanting
to know what an ideal or much
more just or more or less just
economy is, but to say in
response to my argument--
oh no, we shouldn't
argue for right
to strike, surely
what we should argue
for, sort of in the
abstract, is a just economy--
is I think in the context
argument just to say,
when you ask the question
what may actually
existing workers do to resist
the oppression that they faced,
your answer is nothing.
Or argue for an incredibly
remote political ideal
that has little to no
chance of being realized
any time in the short or medium
term within the currently
existing institutions.
So I'm not saying it
isn't worth contemplating
these questions about better
social policies and so on.
But it's a separate question and
not a response to what I think
is the most immediate--
the more immediate--
social and political question.
Which is, when people face a
kind of systematic limitation
on their freedom what
may they do to resist it?
I think the right to strike is
one very important way which
in workers in the economy
can resist that oppression.
So thank you very much.